What is like, and now I'm gonna ask you parenting advice,
if that's okay, 'cause I talk about this with you
when I see you,
what do you guys do to keep the kids safe on social?
There's one thing you did that really really spoke to me,
something about the comment section.
Oh yeah.
Tell me about that
'cause I'm very interested.
Yeah, it's different for the three kids of our five
that are in that picture,
everyone has different rules about social media.
We don't do one size fits all parenting
and we certainly don't do one size fits all
about social media.
So when Zaire, who is one of our oldest, he's now 20.
When he turned 16, all he wanted was his own Instagram.
But when we set it up,
we set it up through my husband's account
so we could see his DMs.
We were all up and through his DMs.
And let me tell you, as much as folks were like,
"Euphoria" is not realistic.
Let me tell you, that show, "Euphoria",
was all up and through my child's comments.
Pretty accurate for teens, scary, yes, I know.
But if you can get into those DMs, try.
But like with Zaya,
she can only see comments from people that she follows.
So unless she follows you, you cannot leave a comment.
But for Kaavia, obviously she can't read.
And for us, with Kaav,
it was important for us to show a free black girl
in all of her moods, whether her hair is done, not done,
you know, whether she's got the cutest outfit on
or she's still in her pajamas on a Saturday evening,
we wanted people to see
what free black girlhood looks like
and we felt that it was important for,
we made people such a part of our heartbreak
with our fertility journey, that when Kaav arrived,
there was so much joy and she represents
so much positivity and hope to so many people.
We wanted people to see what her freedom looked like.
I love your style, I really do, I love it.
Okay, well, speaking of kids, oh my gosh,
I can't even stand it, the Cheaper by the Dozen
remake, reboot.
(audience applauds)
I mean, this is so fun.
Is it true that like Dwayne and Zach
may have known each other or may not have known each other?
What?
They just met on the carpet last night
and there's actual footage of them meeting,
after this press tour where Zach said on Ellen
that he had no idea who Dwayne was,
and then when he looked him up, he was like, oh goodness,
I gotta get in shape.
But yeah, they finally met on the carpet last night,
and both of my husbands, got to meet and they hugged.
They hugged it out, they bro'd it out.
But yeah, it was cute.
(upbeat music)